the kids are back to school and when you
take a look around you see the leftover
signs of the summer so what do you do
you take advantage of zero res is their
extended Labor Day sale and you recover
with an amazingly clean home joining me
to tell us more is Ben and Doug McKee
co-owners and operators of Zerorez Las
Vegas welcome guys hey good to see you
Mercedes good to see you now I was so
excited because I thought you brought me
a little gift but this is uh not the
kind of gift I want but it's the kind of
gift that Zerorez will give you by
taking it out of your home tell me a
little bit about what you have here it
is so this little jar is full of all
these goodies it's the hair it's all
sorts of nasty stuff that lurks in our
carpets even at home but your vacuum
cleaner can't pull it all out but
Zerorez we've got the technology to get
this removed
um I'm shaking around sorry so that you
don't have to live with it in your
carpets anymore yeah you think that
you're cleaning your carpets like okay
it I vacuumed everything's perfect but
that's still living in there and your ZR
technology can get it out how do you
guys do that it can't and like you said
it's really important to vacuum
regularly but the carpet and rug
Institute recommends getting your
carpets professionally cleaned every six
to 18 months just depending on the
traffic and you know your pet situation
you got going on at home but our Zero
Water technology you can see the results
we can remove the toughest stains as
tough as dirt and nasty stuff hiding in
your carpet get it out without any soaps
or surfactants leave your carpets soft
to the touch and it dries super fast
that's what I love that you're not using
any nasty artificial things in my carpet
let's talk not just about carpets
because we're going to get a little demo
here but let's talk about air ducts I've
been wanting to get my air ducts clean
what have you found in people's air
ducts well you're just telling me my
friend found a bird's nest in hers so
not to level you up with another story
but we've actually removed a dead rat
from an air deck before so you don't
know what's hiding in those Ducks get
them professionally cleaned it goes with
making your indoor environment safe
healthy and hygienic and it starts with
the carpets
let's take a look at what Zerorez can do
for your carpets yeah you do it all not
just carpets not just air ducts hardwood
tile all of it and this is my favorite
thing isn't this incredible so
satisfying I don't get bored with this
so right away you can see that zero res
difference you got dirty carpet you got
dual resified carpet and this is with
our gr water technology it's perfect
because if you have kids or pets you
don't have to worry about that stuff and
look we got three swipes and that is
perfectly clean I mean you could eat off
of that carpet thank you guys so much
definitely want to give Zerorez a call
they've got a deal for you thank you
Zerorez for sponsoring the segment take
advantage of their special two rooms of
carpet clean for only 89 deal plus save
20 off of those air ducts you could call
702-840-333 or go online to
zerorezlasvegas.com for more information
minimum fly Las Vegas now